weed sugar and alcohol will not help you  reach your goals if you are serious  about your dreams and you want to  experience uncommon levels of energy and  mental focus stop these five things this  week stop drinking alcohol stop smoking  weed stop refined sugar stop binging  junk content at night and stop staying  up late and not getting enough sleep how  can i guarantee this will work i mean  one the latest research proves it but  two i've personally struggled to stop  all five habits in my own life and found  more energy clarity and overall  well-being as a result and listen if  you're content and satisfied with where  you are right now in life and business  then maybe this isn't for you but if you  want to get out of a rut and reach that  next level remember